it's a mammoth task
mapping photographing and referencing
millions of gravestones in thousands of
graveyards the goal to provide a digital
map of burial sites and records that
will be invaluable to historians and
genealogists and fascinating to the
public
we're here in barton churchyard near
penrith in cumbria and there we can see
the headstones we can see the trees we
can see the graves and again imagining
we're overseas somewhere there we have a
photograph
of that very headstone that we can see
here
obviously these are now protected
because there's
numerous stories of records being lost
through fire or theft or floods up here
in particular for example so they could
be lost with flooding we also have a
copy of the original burial register so
they're protected and also having them
online means people are not having to
manhandle them so they're not being
they're not deteriorating through
through heavy use and abuse and that
sort of thing and as you say they're
accessible from anywhere in the world
exactly
the backpacks the team used to collect
the data cost a hundred thousand pounds
each and contain five cameras two laser
scanners and the latest gps technology
it may only take an hour or so to scan a
graveyard like this but with 50 million
measurements being gathered it can take
up to a week to process that information
and with 19 000 graveyards to be mapped
the seven year timescale for this
project could be a tight one
once the initial data has been fed into
the system the local parishes themselves
can keep the online records updated the
survey put into context everything
within the churchyard the building the
headstones and even the vegetation
and what we learned at that point was
where the old maps weren't exact in in
scale in detail so we've had that
immediate advantage
there are benefits for ecologists
biologists and botanists too the data
gathered by this study will also be used
as part of a national biodiversity
survey of the sometimes very rare plants
and animals that are living amongst our
dead
fraser moored sky news penrith